oh
that can't be good oh is it the beast
from beneath the boards oh beautiful so
red oh yeah oh she's like just do it
just yeah she's like here it goes yeah
just kidding I just wanted I bet that
smells awful oh
that would probably knock me out I'd be
like I can smell she knows she knows she
knows she knows
she's like you have to live with this
now bye she's like and you know exactly
where I'm going how dare you lock me in
my room how dare you lock me in my room
exactly where I'm going fly
I went oh I love this okay you guys
we're gonna get into it because welcome
back to New rockstars we've got a new
King in King's Landing and his
coronation went rather well as long as
you didn't have general admission uh
stand in only floor seats oh my God you
guys this that's why I never sit on the
floor because the dragon event because
you know what's beneath the boards you
never know you never know what's beneath
the boards
are you a dreamer
you guys how is Renea going to respond
to all of this action I mean I'm
guessing not well I think she should
show up with maybe three dragons maybe
four at least hey crack open the other
eggs
open let's bring all the dragon this is
the big question presents talking
dragons are weakly fantasy after show
you guys uh I'm Jessica Clemens and with
me today is Brandon Barrick hello
Jessica what an episode huh some crazy
stuff I'm gonna kill sir Christian Cole
yeah he's gonna kill him he's on my Hit
List uh yeah we're gonna talk uh the
most recent episode of House of the
Dragon episode nine uh today we're not
gonna spoil anything that might be
coming from the future in the books we
could talk about Game of Thrones that's
fine that's way in the future we'll talk
about stuff that maybe happened in the
books leading up to this point but no
spoilers if you haven't read the book
don't worry about that we're just gonna
talk about the episode today is this the
is next week the finale yeah this was
the penultimate episode the episode
before the last episode uh so next week
will be the finale so we're so excited
for that but let's dive into this
episode episode nine of House of the
Dragon the green Council uh it's morning
in King's Landing and viserys stop stop
doing this you always start with like
it's a funeral
I mean it
it's morning time people are finding out
news is slowly spreading around the red
keep but before this news gets too far
Otto and Allison call the small Council
together to discuss the plan and Allison
is somewhat shocked to learn that most
of the council including her father Otto
have been secretly planning for this day
and how they should get aegon onto the
throne this is when I was like I texted
you and I was like I can't be on
tomorrow's episode I was like from the
jump you were like this scene I wanted
to fast forward through so bad I was
like you guys I can't stand yeah I was
kind of surprised how shocked she was by
all this yeah there was that I yeah she
doesn't deserve to be shocked by any of
the right people conspiracy with her dad
who's been conspiracy with her so it's
like you're you don't deserve to be
shook but she was genuinely sad to learn
that viserys had died which was
interesting yeah I think you know
however they got together and however
their relationship was I think over time
she did have a spot in her heart for him
she could still be mad about this
situation and still be unhappy about you
know being forced to have sex with him
and all that stuff but I think at some
point she found some sort of solace in
him yeah I mean as a actual father
figure and a father she he was much
better than
Otto yeah maybe so that's gonna be like
it's good to his daughter I don't know
about his other kids not good to the
other kids but uh now that Allison says
it was viserys's dying wish to see aegon
Ascend to the throne it seems like the
plan is to go my favorite thing about
this episode is every time she tells
someone like yes viserys said that aegon
should uh Ascend to the throne
everyone's response is like uh-huh sure
okay yeah No One Believes No One
Believes the first one that didn't
believe her yeah this is the one I got
really upset because you heard me last
week you heard me what I said about this
man I like this man yeah so everyone's
discussing like okay let's get the plan
going Allison's like what's going on uh
and someone else is not keen to this
plan our good old friend Lord beesberry
the old man himself he won't hear of
this treason he also won't hear of Sir
Kristen Cole coming up behind him R.I.P
Lord beesberry I I like how they made
him a stand-up dude he was like this is
treason I won't have this I knew viserys
longer than any of you this is BS he's
like the King was fine when he went to
bed last night does anyone actually
believe he just died I love that he even
brought up that he was like I mean yeah
he was a Walking Corpse but also like
weird that he would die last night after
the family has already gone back home
and he tells one person like oh just
kidding I want aegon to be on the throne
yeah
our trusty psycho Kristen Cole bashes
his head in on this marble table I also
love if you'll notice when they pull
this Council together uh before they get
to the official business and Otto's kind
of checking in to see if like everyone's
still cool with this plan once it seems
like it's gonna happen then he puts his
marble in
Otto is so interesting about like how he
plays this game where it's like
unofficially are we all cool with aegon
taking the throne yes okay boom now okay
let's talk about it okay uh someone else
doesn't like this plan and it's also sir
Harold westerling head of the kingsguard
uh and when he's told to go round up
Ramirez and the family and give them a
chance to give up the crown or die he
tears off his white cloak and heads out
another man joining team black he's not
having this BS and he's been hating
Kristen Cole for years and once like
this happens and no one does anything
he's like I'm out of here I'm surprised
he was able to walk freely yeah like I'm
surprised I know it wasn't like
Christian yeah I wasn't sure if he was
gonna make it out of the castle but we
saw in the uh teaser for next week he's
at Dragonstone so he got out of the
castle he got out I love him yeah yeah I
love him I love him I hate sir Chris
he's a good man you guys the race is on
to find aegon this is Rat Race yeah this
becomes a show this becomes uh the
entire episode and it's so funny uh who
appears to have snuck out of the keep so
both Otto and Allison want to be the
first to talk to aegon rightfully so
Allison isn't keen on killing rhemara
and her family so she wants to draw
aegon to her side she sends her Kristen
Cole and aim on after her firstborn son
the way she kind of uses Chris to go
here she pulls them in close like for
your queen
I don't know yeah yeah I don't know
we'll get into what happened at the very
end of the episode but that was a little
too she really gets in close and really
uses her paw as your trusted yeah I was
like trust in what trust in who yeah she
only she she really chooses her moments
to be close to this psychopath that was
an eye-opener for me I was like okay all
right
[ __ ] is power
that's what they saying that's what
they're saying so
Otto sends Eric and Eric I'll try to
emphasize the a versus the E the two
twins after aegon but little does he
know that Eric with an e is not so hot
on aegon anymore he's been aegon's Chief
guard and has uh seen the bad things he
gets up to all the time
some bad things
oh well okay let's get going as both
teams search the pillow houses and child
fighting rings the flea bottoms for
aegon the White Worm sends a message to
Otto through the cargile twins uh pay up
and I'll tell you where he's had eight
where I hit aegon also be nicer to the
little kids of King's Landing and I love
this this is what I was like go at it
yeah yeah I said go at it girl Otto's
like sure yeah I'll get right on yeah I
was like okay yeah tell me where it goes
so the babies the aegon babies well
we'll definitely get into all that but
this child fighting ring was wild I got
sharpen their teeth and their their
fingernails
I was watching it and I was like
sharpened teeth and fingernails I was
like put me in well if if you've read
the books uh when they were searching
for aegon I was a little worried about
where they would find him he's up to
some allegedly again the books are kind
of like unreliable the narrator you're
hearing different stories one of them
coming from mushroom who's like a fool a
Jester in the court who tells a lot of
body Tales but they find aegon in the
book in a very compromising position
with someone who is underage uh just
kind of whether it's the book of the
show aegon gets up to something yeah and
the fact that he's coming to this child
fighting ring he's betting on it he's
putting his own bastards into it messed
up it's just so messed up insane yeah no
wonder Eric with any is like this guy is
Bad News Bears and his brother's like
but we took an oath and it's like uh
let's bring that out well it was also
like clear that he just saw it and was
like because he was like over there he's
there for the first time and he's like
whoa whoa what what and Eric was he is
like I'm here too much literally insane
yeah so both teams are now searching for
aegon pretty much agree that he
shouldn't be king yeah even his brother
aemon makes the case that he should be
king which no but also yes I understand
um second Sons am I right I mean second
son's always be like they feel like they
need as a second born as a second born I
have an older brother uh I'm the best
and I should get all of the claims as a
firstborn oh I think that I should get
all the claim uh and should definitely
uh
I double down on my duties a second
board and I don't think you do but but
this part is kind of not I don't feel
any sadness but I love that aegon was
like please dude I will dip out right
now and you can take this just let me go
yeah he Eamon thought about it he thinks
about it he does that when they're
walking around you know he's walking
around with Kristen Cole good buddies
he's like you know we might not even
find my brother he could be dead he
could be on the way to Yeti I love a
good reference to yiti a far away land
uh uh on a different continent far far
from Westeros uh and he's kind of hoping
like they don't find him right because
he's like according to the great Council
and what was established before because
aegon has kids right so in theory if
they don't find aegon you can make one
of his kids the next king but they
there's always when they had like the
great counsel that decided vasera should
be king right one of the arguments was
that like uh uh you should it should go
down to the next brother especially if
they're old enough to take it like if if
the because in the book it's not so much
rainy spying for it it's her son Lenor
right niece's case is that my son Lenor
should take it and everyone's like Ray
Nordstrom young he can't be in charge
it's a bad time so that's kind of sets
the precedent for viserys taking it so
eamon's like if we don't find aegon it
should go to me according to like the
great Council but they do find aegon
he's he's hiding under the uh he's
hiding in the great step underneath the
same altar his mother and rhaenyra
prayed at many years ago as friends I
think in the second episode we saw him
praying there maybe the first episode
after a scuffle between sir Kristen Cole
and Eric with an e aegon and amen the
king to B is brought in Kicking and
Screaming he clearly does not want this
job uh he has a little slap fight with
his brother he's like please please stop
begging you don't don't make it it's
okay funny that amen is always has the
upper hand the brothers
sword he's just like come on I love
you really like gaming uh meanwhile
reinise has been locked in her room all
day wondering what the hell is going on
she's still in King's Landing they're
still stitching up Damon's body to get
it ready to go back to driftmark uh but
she's not uh allowed out of her room she
can see all this stuff going on and
Allison finally comes to see her uh and
she begins to put the pieces together
right reynise realizes that her cousin
viserys is dead and Allison is usurping
the throne for her son the rhonice
wonders why Allison doesn't take it for
herself I think it was okay
I think it was all I think it was just
her being like like not edging her but
like nagging her being like oh well you
don't want the power well yes yes right
I think she kind of sees through this uh
she says to Allison quote and yet you
you toil still in the service of men you
desired not to be free but make a window
in the wall of your prison which is
basically like you know you say you're
doing all this stuff uh for you and for
your family but you're really doing
things on behalf of other men and not
putting yourself in power uh because uh
Allison says to rainy it's like you
should have been
Queen you should have been ruling which
is a and uh Raines kind of respects that
because she's like I don't think you
would ever say that you know look where
you are but she's like no but Sarah
should have been a country Lord reading
books and building his little house
right uh and you should have been Queen
but she's really sweet talking ramese
here I think she definitely is but I
also like that line of like especially
even after being like you should have
been Queen and it's like and I wasn't
and here we are now yeah and you are
begging me and look at this yeah look at
all this Allison Allison wants raynes
for her side and Promises Promises her
drift Mark and her granddaughter's
Legacy uh she agrees that Renee should
have been Queen Allison's move here has
surprised and impressed Ray niece uh and
she's left in her room to pick a sign
come out when you have an answer and it
better be the right one uh because you
know Allison points out that rainis has
melis her dragon and she certainly
doesn't want another Dragon going back
to Rainier she's like Leave Your Dragon
here let's be on our side we need some
help how many dragons enough uh we'll
get into the dragon count we'll have
that a little later today uh okay so
with aegon secured Allison confronts her
father about how he used her like a
chess piece and he basically says gee
thanks glad you know he's like so proud
he's like yeah to make a good job yeah
you're like you're the queen now so be
happy also like Allison get wise to this
much earlier yeah you dummy uh you dummy
but also I'm like
It's like because he's like aren't you
happy and she's like I don't know I
didn't have a choice yeah yeah I wish I
would have known she's like I don't know
what it's like to not be the queen like
you kind of pushed me into that push me
in this dude yeah uh also warns her to
get over the fact that she doesn't want
to kill her childhood friend but Allison
wants to do this all without Bloodshed
which I mean sure go ahead try her plan
is to have a big public crowning of
aegon in front of all the small folk
yeah
um yeah it's it's really rude of Otto to
be like you're only being like this
because Rainier is your friend and it's
like you ruined her friendship you you
started it yeah dude you are the I might
have like I might yes that might be true
but you are the one at the end of all
this yes and it's clear Otto's
intentions of bringing Allison into the
castle with him were to like find a way
to gain power and initially I think that
was through being friends with Ramirez
yeah but then when the opportunity arose
to like push her on to viserys he like
went for it yeah I also I'm like
it's just it's I'm not trying to be a
horrible person but I'm like yeah I mean
now you just got you can't go back yeah
you got to work with what you have now
and you I mean you don't have to listen
to your dad but you can't even even your
dad can't well wander with what would
happen in the past and Allison is
clearly in this like sunk cost fallacy
she's like I've come this far aegon's a
piece of [ __ ] but like it's the best
play I have right now so we're gonna go
for it
idiots not a single person has brought
it up yet Allison has a surprise meeting
with her good friend Laris
she's like where's it's a little late
for this and we're like a little way for
what and we find out
oh boy
I'll talk about it for a second okay so
Alice has a surprise meeting with a good
friend Laris who warns her about the web
of spies in the castle the Otto has
taken advantage of on many occasions
it's how they learned where aegon was
hiding uh lares agrees to go all psycho
killer on the head of the rumor of the
rumor web
you know the people that we also learned
that Allison has been paying for a price
for laris's efforts and all it costs is
10 little people I mean uh genuinely I
genuinely immediately went good deal
like you get a man that kill you from
just showing you like a top of your calf
at the lower end of your calf and some
footsies I mean they really focused on
his club foot again this episode right
before this all right and like the idea
that like the man with a foot deformity
has like this insane football I think
that's what they're trying to I think
that's what they're trying to say is
like oh he fetishizes her the Queen's
feet the Queen's feet that are like too
good to even touch the ground yeah like
I but it's also like I think it's
interesting because I'm like yeah most
people that do have the foot fetish it's
a power thing a power Dynamic yeah and
so I'm like it could be more power
Dynamic than it is even leaning like oh
I don't have the foot that you have I
think it could just be like well it's
also like who has seen the Queen's feet
like yeah exactly and she has to take
off like five things to show up Barefoot
so I genuinely was like because when she
put her foot up I was like oh she chills
like I do I was like that's that's
different because it's 2022 that's like
AC and then when she starts taking it
off I was like oh if you go back and
watch me right before she takes her
shoes off he kind of like starts looking
downstairs I had to go back and Rewind
uh he knows what just to do I watched
the entire episode and I went only back
to that scene because I genuinely was
like was it was it clear I was like I
didn't notice it and then he's just done
it she's able to do it so many times
she's like sick of it the way she like
turns away she's like
sit under his little cake
and she was already disgusted with him
after he like Butters his own family and
all this and now we've learned that like
part of the reason for her never wanted
to be around him is that every time he
has comes around got information and
it's gonna cost money
I I I I I was just like when did it
start after did he like was it and we
were always like what's his plan right
what's his plan I think this is just
like his plan he's like I get off
because you give and I give you Secrets
yeah so I think that was like ultimately
like he talked to her first gave her a
little bit you know like give her a
little taste and then was like well now
I need something
I get off when the stockings come off
like with the knee decides to bust
rainis out of the red keep and get her
out of the city by boat he's tired of
all this this is BS he's had enough uh
but before they can make it to the
harbor they are swept up in the crowds
of small folk being led into the dragon
pit for the coronation which is exactly
where Raines wants to go she's like oh
hell yeah let's go she doesn't want to
leave for Dragon May least behind aegon
rides to the dragon pit with Allison and
the carriage who tells him to shape up
and not kill Rainier's family she also
gives him the famed Valerian steel
dagger that uh viserys carried with him
all time that has the song of ice and
fire on it though none of them know that
uh and this is where we learned that
like yeah he's like my dad never loved
me if he really wanted me to be king he
should have said so for like 20 years
but he never did No One Believes you mom
when you say that he changed his mind
but we're going with this uh at the
coronation the crowd is pretty
unimpressed by the whole Affair uh
learning that the king is dead and the
succession plans have changed all in one
sentence all in the same day it's kind
of like while like they're all just what
about their business they get forced
into the dragon pit and they're like the
King's dead and you got a new king and
everyone's I like how they're kind of
like
yeah we're all confused there's like
rumor they're all murmuring into each
other uh but aegon is crowned with the
conqueror's crown and handed blackfyre
so this was the crown that aegon
originally wore when he took when he the
original they took over the Seven
Kingdoms he wore this Crown uh and
blackfyre was the sword that he wielded
we saw viserys carry this sword uh
throughout the series though he mainly
like leaned on it as a crutch he never
really wielded it
um no one can really even look at aegon
when he's crowned because everyone knows
this is a bad idea his brother his
mother his wife sir Kristen Cole they're
all like this is a terrible idea but
when aegon turns to address his people
he's greeted with the love and
admiration he's been seeking his whole
life and he loves it they love me Mama
Everyone likes me who cares if my mom
and dad doesn't love me the people love
me which is
very dangerous I mean when he started
pumping that sword out I was like great
they dressed him in Black he's a bad guy
get it together uh and just when
everything's going so well Boom the
beast from beneath the boards arrive
rainis comes through the floor on the
back of melis she's got the greens right
where she wants them but chooses to only
scare the [ __ ] out of them instead of
burning them alive uh though I'm pretty
sure at least a few hundred small folk
died in the mail maybe a thousand who
knows we saw people get whipped by the
tail dangerous uh she flies off to
Dragonstone to let rhaenyra and the Gang
know what's up
and that sets us up for next week and
for all of this to come to an exciting
conclusion
I can't wait to see it but before we do
that be sure to head over to new
rockstarsmerch.com where there's still
time to grab our latest Obsession shirt
Ashton ruin inspired by the house of the
Dragon Series this limited edition shirt
will be gone faster than a small folk
hanging out on the floor of the Dragon
pit uh so make sure to grab one when you
can check out all of our great merch
options over at New rockstarsmerch.com
all right well Jessica uh this was a
crazy episode of course they've all been
crazy this season it seems like uh but I
think the big question we got to address
today
did Ray nice make a huge mistake here I
mean would she decides to not just torch
everyone on standing on the Deus is this
a is this a bad idea now we know it's
not going to happen obviously because
this show has to keep going on but this
was not in the books originally okay
this was some uh in the books rhaenice
is uh at driftmark when she learns about
her cousin dying and all that stuff so
this was a big change they made here uh
they really give her a moment of agency
I think the main reason she doesn't do
it is because she would be a kin Slayer
if she does this and that's like kind of
a bad thing that's like a the ultimate
sin right uh if you're familiar with
Game of Thrones you know Jaime Lannister
was called the king Slayer because he
killed the king uh and he hated that
moniker it stuck with him everywhere so
if if rhenice torches everyone here she
becomes a kinslayer and maybe even a
king Slayer depending on who you believe
uh if you think aegon should be the king
uh so I think that's kind of why she
backed off here yeah and didn't torch
them I agree do you think there's
anything else behind her like motivation
no I also well I mean there's no one
left to house Valerian except for really
her her so it's like and her
granddaughter she doesn't really see her
son they're about to become targaryens
valerians but um not to be horrible it's
three people three people total and all
three women so the realm is already
probably overlooking like just being
like whatever yeah
um so it's like I think she knows what
she'll lose if she goes up against the
Hightower slash targaryens yeah like
it's like not only is that my family but
I'm a house Valerian now and I need to
represent house Valerian and if I die
there will only be two members left to
house Valerian whose last name is about
to change to Targaryen so Targaryen
Rhymes but yeah I think she knows what
she can lose and that's what I respected
she's becoming one of my favorite
characters yeah because of that she's
just genuinely like I have to stand for
myself like even if she doesn't go
straight to Rainer which I think she's
gonna go uh she's also like
I have one Dragon
like I I have my house I I'm about to
lose everything if I fight with you like
I can't do that right yeah she would she
did not want to leave her dragon in
King's Landing that was like a big thing
and that's a big if she would have left
it even when Eric's trying to get her on
our boat she's like I'm not leaving my
dragon that's a dumb idea crazy uh Eamon
would have been like vegar eat eat that
Dragon yeah yeah eat that Dragon uh I
think another telling moment during this
whole sequence uh is Allison says to
Christian Cohen that Dragon when they're
facing melees he's like get Helena yeah
she doesn't care about aegon
Eamon I think she likes but is afraid of
well Eamon also has a dragon so I think
maybe she was like expecting him to be
able to hold his own he can take care of
the stage
he knows how to get out of here but like
I I found it very telling that the
really the the kid she cares about the
most is yeah even when they were talking
and she was like the big side of the
floorboards yeah like she was like honey
no like she cared about her the most
which is true she's the best out of the
three yeah I I thought that was like
really interesting
um I do love to raynese you know coming
in kind of watching the ceremony happen
she's watching aegon be Crown King again
another coronation that's not hers right
the queen that never was she sees the
another unworthy man getting the crown
put on his head by Sir Kristen Cole
which was very interesting too well I
think she's more so upset that it's like
uh what that guy said they're oath
Breakers yeah they're oath Breakers we
heard what the king said we all like
bent the knee to rain era like I don't
care that it was 20 something years ago
it's like we are oath Breakers to the
original King the first king before or
not the first but you know before aegon
so I think she's more so like I how can
I trust them you guys are gonna you
already bet one rule right like even if
the king said this to one person in one
room that no one else was in none of us
can believe you like it makes no sense
so I think that's where
is is like we we really hold words to us
like that's why uh Coralis was like that
is my grandson they're not going to
remember blood they're going to remember
names so I think she's like standing
with words yeah she does say when her
and Allison have their little chat in
her room she says to Allison something
along the lines of like my family's word
my House's word is not so fickle right
like that but as she's being you know
kind of uh escaped from the red keep by
Eric with an E she sees Lord Carson Eric
with an e oh got it uh she sees Lord
Coswell hanging in in the in in the
courtroom what did they do to the other
two wow do they just let them leave I
don't know are they in jail they might
be in jail they might get a second
chance do you know I don't know I don't
know I don't know I was in there uh they
might get a second chance right we we
saw early in the episode that Talia and
all the other servants that know about
the King's death were immediately taken
down to the jail messed up uh and then
when they bring together some Lords and
they're like here's the new plan a bunch
of them immediately take a knee a few
stand firm and they get let Away
by the royal guard who goes from red to
Green did you notice some like green
colors on on these guards now I said
hurry up and get the seamstress get the
green out baby green out uh but they get
let down and then like Lord Coswell he
tries to kind of Escape yeah get out uh
and he was the one in the previous
episode when Rainer and Damon came back
he was the one that greeted them uh when
no one else really greeted them at
King's Landing he was like oh my
princess you're back he was clearly on
team runner from the from the jump and
he got hung for it and so this is
something that rainy sees that like
Allison and Otto are not messing around
and if you do not come to terms with
them they will hang you they will kill
you like this whole series yeah she
knows this is real so when she busts
through you know
she's telling them like I'm not on your
side but I think she can also see she I
don't want to kill you because it's
going to be bad for my house and my name
I think she also sees how afraid they
are of the Dragon which we're going to
get into a little bit more uh do you
think do you think she's is Raines more
manned or more disappointed I think
disappointed yeah because I think she
those words that she exchanged with
Allison I do think they were both
hearing each other for a minute but
she's just like I remember when you were
young like I was and she was she was
there for everything that's true she's
like look at you like you don't even
care anymore like you're not you're not
ruling with like emotion anymore you're
just ruling with power and listening to
your dad yeah so I think she's just
disappointed in everybody and what
everything's going I think she is
disappointed because I'm sure Ray niece
has heard the rumors of aegon that he's
not a good dude he she knows that
Allison knows he's not a good guy and
like the fact that she's going through
with all this instead of taking power
for herself she's really disappointed in
it and just like I don't even I don't
even don't waste the Dragonfire the
thing is like and I hate it sucks it
sucks honestly the worst position to be
in is raining uh rainey's position
because it's like everyone's like we
need you because you have dragons yeah
we need you because of this we need you
because of this and she's like my son's
baby my husband's dead yeah the
brother's dead my two daughters are
about to get married no no her husband's
dead yet he's not there he's right there
she hasn't been home to check out yet
he's not he's not here I just want to
get my dragon I want to get the hell out
of here she also was like I I love my
cousin I love him but I also like he's
dead let me just go let me leave and
they're like just keep they're like lock
the door lock the door you can't leave
that also that log and she's just like
no one answers her yeah do you know how
mad I would be I'm a princess yeah I
would go off I would have been like I'm
gonna kill everybody I'm gonna get the
Navy
try getting on the water again in the
water uh yeah yeah I think she's just
really just really pissed about this
whole situation she's she's in the worst
position I'm allowed to be disappointed
and not care at the same time right or
she would be yeah I would yeah well I
think she might get a little Revenge I
don't know we'll see what happens uh we
got lots more to talk about in this
episode but first we want to thank our
sponsor today Verity Verity is all about
clothing for life's best moments whether
it's a Friday night football game the
first day of school or hanging with the
family in your backyard this fall they
make clothes that feel good and make you
feel good Verity is a family brand that
believes comfort and quality are key
they make the kind of clothes you can
make those magical memories in from the
beach to the woods to that cool arts
district in your downtown area have you
been to the downtown Arts District I
heard about it on She-Hulk oh okay well
you should go down there dressed in
Faraday Verity is passionate about
craftsmanship and sustainability every
piece is designed to be a lifetime
favorite in fact their clothes get even
better with age just like me and if
anything happens along the way Verity
will replace or fix your clothes for
life no matter what layer your favorite
pieces for a cozy fall Vibe like the
best-selling soft and stretchy Legend
sweater shirt that has thousands of five
stars reviews in fact I'm wearing it
right now that's right this is a fairyty
shirt right here give me one oh no it's
just funny it's so soft it's very comfy
I like it and especially this time of
year oh yeah this is perfect yeah I
really like it because like but it's
kind of getting a little chilly in L.A I
say a little chilly it dips into the I
put it I put on pants and a big puffy
black jacket from New York and I'm like
yeah we act like it's uh Minnesota
around here but I can wear this during
the day and roll down the sleeves at
night I'm comfy I'm cool it's great you
butthole I know right now parody is
giving oh big question fans an amazing
deal 20 off on every order that's right
you get a full 20 off on your order head
over to ferritybrand.com bigquestion and
use code big question to check out to
get this deal that's called big question
at Verity
f-a-h-e-r-t-ybrand.com bigquestion for
20 off veritybrand.com big question
um do you know what else gets better
with age what's that
remember this thing where he's getting
wrapped by the I said I said enough
close-ups also that scene was really
good I like I like any uh when we get
shots of the silent sisters because I
started paying attention to like the
design on their backs yeah I think and I
was like Yeah The Silent sisters are
metal as hell they're really cool I
don't need any more Masters show me
these girls like they're cool as hell do
the silent sisters working at red the
red keeper they're there all the time
now they're another dead royalty oh here
we go can't talk to anybody about it
anybody about it they're like do you
think they talk to each other when they
go to their little room they're like no
they drop that dude's head off they I
feel like they can also it's like I
think they were like when they were like
who knows about viserys death and it's
like well silent sisters but we don't
gotta worry about them that's right uh
so let's get into our next topic for
today uh and I think it's an important
one are the greens ready for like a real
dragon battle okay uh we went through
this before let's let's do a Dragon
count okay so by my estimation Team
Green Allison and the Gang they have
about five who has dragons Okay so aegon
has Sunfire yes all right uh uh which we
maybe saw in in the The Wedding though
yeah the funeral episode a drift Mark
when we saw those dragons sitting around
so he has Sunfire uh Helena has a dragon
called dream fire we haven't really seen
her riding it yet I don't know how
competent she is on a dragon especially
for battle do you think we're gonna see
her on the dragon I don't know I mean it
would be crazy I don't think she's gonna
get on the door she doesn't seem like
the temperament for like a battle but
she's also like very focused and if you
tell her like Helena we need you to do
this to protect your kids she might she
might but I also don't think she wants
to have violence I don't think she wants
that smoke yeah I mean we saw when Damon
got that Hedgehog but she was like no no
and also like aegon's
Punk yeah hey God doesn't seem like he's
very confident okay so brother sister
husband wife came to me and was like I
need you to get on your dragon and fight
for me I be like [ __ ] you
I don't like you anyways well let's talk
about the the best one they got Eamon
has vegar okay vegar right now it's like
the biggest dragon in the world yeah
that's like two dragons has seen a lot
of battle has conquered Westeros is a
bad ass Dragon okay and this has been
aemond we know is confident incompetent
on this Dragon okay that's a big one
that's a that's two dragons that's two
dragons so they got six yeah so that's
that's like yeah those are the three
like grown dragons we know of there are
like aegon and Helena have two kids
right now and they have baby dragons as
far as I know okay but I doubt they're
ready for battle they're they're not on
the team so we'll say like they have
five dragons total but three that are
ready to fight and that's why they
really want maylese uh they want Ray
niece on their side now let's go over to
team black okay uh Ranier in the game
they got like six dragons okay we got
Cyrax which is rhaenyra's Dragon we've
seen it it's great it's already laying
eggs we got caraxis which is Damas
Dragon another badass dragon the blood
worm okay good dragon joserus has ver
Max uh which we saw as a child when the
dragon pit when he's still learning to
train it not bad it might be a little
more grown now could put up a fight
lucerus has air X which we have not seen
yet uh and it might be old enough
luceras is getting older so it might be
old enough to fight uh of course rhaenys
has melis good Dragon uh the Red Queen I
believe it's called very beautiful very
strong very powerful Baylor has a dragon
named Moon dance which I don't think
we've seen yet uh but what could be a
good fighter a stupid name uh this isn't
bad all of their names is our besties
the max Moon day well the problem is
they start letting the kid's name dragon
fire truck yeah yeah spot scaly
don't let your kid name the pets okay uh
let's not forget though the team black
has sea smoke uh this was leonor's
Dragon they have it at the Dragonstone I
don't know if anyone's writing it yet in
theory uh Elena could hop on that dragon
or not late night uh the other one
Bayless sister could hop on the dragon
uh plus we know they have some eggs now
too uh for the new kids so they're
collecting dragons they're growing
dragons they got a hot Dragon Squad but
also I think if we're just comparing the
dragons to dragons
um clearly rhaenyra's family are more
confident dragons
the thing is like the dragons can be
dragons but who can control the dragons
and we saw that in episode two I think
where viserys was like we should have
never tried to control these dragons
because we can't so it's gonna be a lot
of like bonding and just working
together and I just think renner's team
has been ready yeah they've got the
practice you know they've got the stats
yeah they're ready for this fight it was
also very notable you know uh when uh
Alice and the gangs having to stare down
with me at least they all look so scared
like they're scared of dragons they you
know the high Towers they're married
into this BS like they don't know these
are the nuclear weapons of Westeros
they're very frightened of them I think
the other ones are much more confident
you know raniera and the Gang they're
very confident they're not messing
around they're ready for this fight my
favorite Banderas
they're right they're like you wanna
have a dragonfly let's have a Dragonfire
they're they're true and then also it's
like you have rain Nera and Damon
leading it dude like those two have been
playing with their dragons since day
woman was fighting in the stepstone he
knows how to fight what are you guys
ready to go about you guys have been
burning strawman literal Straw Men
literally and I'm like the only fighter
they really have is amen yeah I think
Eamon would be the Ammon not vegard that
you bring up that's like two or three
dragons and he that dragon is gonna eat
another Dragon I guarantee it we're
gonna see that Dragon rip apart another
Dragon which will probably honestly be
luceres it's happened before in the book
uh Fire and Blood uh there was a little
battle uh the battle under the God's eye
I believe where like one Dragon rips off
the wing of another Dragon just badass
stuff it's really cool stuff those
dragons are gonna be yeah I want to see
some dragon fighting yeah they can't
wait yeah because Game of Thrones the
dragons were all on the same side let's
see some dragons fighting each other uh
here's my next point for you Jessica
will the small folk forever hate the
dragons 100 what a day to be a small
focaling in King's Landing you wake up
in your
yeah you're ready to like sell your
wares and then you're getting ushered
into this yeah you're like you're going
to the you're going to the Town Square
you're going to sell some stuff gonna
eat some rats or something yeah the the
gold cloaks show up oh great were they
gonna cut off my knife yeah it's gonna
happen today they're gonna go with me
they're like I want to go this way
you're like I don't want to go this way
where are we going you're going in the
dragon pit you're like oh maybe there's
gonna be a show like why is it so many
people in here yeah you gotta stand on
the ground and they're like King's dead
new king you're like uh I feel like we
some of us knew this I heard the rumor
yeah and I don't care can I go back to
harvesting go back please all the
soldiers come out they do a fun thing
with the swords they're like oh this is
cool can I leave uh you're like oh I've
seen that young guy and flea bottom
before bringing a horse I think I had
sex with my daughter sick with my
daughter I don't know can I get out of
here yet oh oh he's King now okay great
yeah yeah yeah yeah could I go boom now
I'm dead or not even dangerous like oh
yeah what the [ __ ] are you gonna swiped
with a dragon tail and you're maimed for
life and now you gotta go see a maester
who's gonna be like let's Lead You
everyone's afraid of the let's licha
everyone's afraid of the Dragons we're
all afraid of the Dragons every
rightfully so it's a creature that can
literally take out an entire unit with
just one breath so it's like give them
more fear give them more reason and
everyone fear you hate you don't want so
everyone's gonna get so angry at the
dragons and that's also why I think
rainey's made a big mistake was busting
through there in the middle of
everything because people are gonna be
like I don't want to vote for the side
of dragon right right but when they see
it when they see Team black ride in on a
bunch of dragons they're gonna be like
no no more of these dragons or maybe
they'll be like they're gonna protect us
from
right like they're maybe they're gonna
get the misleading idea that rhaenyra
sent her cousin to her aunt to go do
yeah they don't know what's happening
they don't know what's happening behind
the scenes and then when they pull up
with the dragons they're gonna be like
you're safe also this is all which I
hate more than anything in life Word of
Mouth just like he said she said so it's
like they're gonna tell the entire small
folk like we're here to protect they're
here to kill and then they're like
they're here to kill and right now is
gonna be like no I'm not like I'm here
to take my crown how's this gonna be
like he changed his mind last minute and
everyone's gonna be like okay yeah sure
okay
um because we know in the future like in
Game of Thrones right at some point uh
there's like a rebellion in King's
Landing man like destroyed the dragon
pit I think this is like the beginning
of those rumors because if you think
back to the first episode when we see
Rainier flying Cyrax over King's Landing
people are looking up and on wonder oh
we love the dragons they protect us
they're great they're awesome this is
like the beginning of like yo my brother
was at the coronation he's dead now
because these dragons
also it's like
how are you going to trust in in an
entire team of people that are fighting
their family you're gonna be like a
small folk that's like dude let's just
not vote for any Targaryen ever again
because they just fight each other
that's all they do do you think that
viserys was a somewhat of a dreamer some
of his dreams come true some of them
don't you know like you brought up
earlier Jessica he warned Rainier like
we should have never messed with these
dragons they will be our undoing and
they are they already are dude they
already are they're fighting mainly for
the dragons they're like we need more uh
something else I want to bring up
Jessica
let's talk about my guy maester Orwell
who's really Keen to support aegon as
Heir or he seems like he's aware of this
plan yeah uh because well yeah when they
have this small council meeting the
green Council will call it right the
only ones who really object to all this
are beesbury
and and westerling who tears off his
cloak and walks out maester Orwell is
kind of like yeah let's make this plan
happen yeah because aegon's going to
keep him busy
my guy
uh there's this there's this Theory out
there uh in in the annals of the
internet uh that the maesters because
it's a maester in every Castle right
they they all kind of work together they
have terrible medicine practices they're
leaching they're putting poultices on
people they're chopping up phlegms but
that the maesters they don't like the
Targaryen yeah because they're the
targaryens came to Westeros they took
over you know they've they've the
maesters and the faith they've all kind
of formed a little bit of a truce to the
targaryens but there's this theory that
the maesters are slowly working to undo
the Targaryen yeah and I think maester
Orwell here he knows that like yeah
let's put aegon on let's get him in here
lean more high tower and this will undo
everything well I think it's just even
like yeah I don't want rhaenyra coming
in I'd rather have like someone who's
half Hightower and the Hightower is
getting a little more charged because
the high towers are from Old Town they
were the big Powerhouse in the land
before the Targaryen showed up so yeah I
do think Mr Orwell is like I'm okay with
this messed up plan that goes against
the succession rules uh as long as it
keeps like the the wrong targaryens out
about the right targaryens out of power
he doesn't want he wants to do the
target well yeah and it's still a
Targaryen but it's more a high tower
than it is a Targaryen also uh what I
made the joke about the maester I meant
more so that coming back to it I meant
more so because aegon's gonna be killing
a lot of people oh yeah you will
probably be assaulting a lot of people
he's going to be doing that too the poor
maester's gonna be like there's too many
dead bodies everywhere and women
scattered throughout the buildings
that's the other thing uh and this was
brought up early in the season too right
it's been a long time of Peace in King's
Landing relative peace relatives Joe
Harris the consolidator was like very
peaceful and when they're you know Otto
several times says viserys the peaceful
and reminds the people of King's Landing
at the coronation this was viserys the
peaceful so it's been a very peaceful
time it's not going to be so peaceful
anymore it's not going to be peaceful
anymore yeah I just thought it was
really interesting because I would have
expected maester or what I'll be like
what is this plane all about but he's
all about this plan yes and yes yes he's
about to plan yeah
yeah uh but also I I what I did like was
he seemingly was the only person that's
like let us handle Lord beesberry he's
still like a man of the council like
yeah he's like let's get the body and he
said no one I was like no one's leaving
and look at the reminder of what will
happen to you if you disagree with him
yes I'm just gonna move my marble a
little further up oh Lannister gets up
jumps away and then just calmly sits
back next to the dead body dude I like I
like lettuce when they kind of roll the
marble down to him like is that cheers
or something yeah a pint of beer he's
like yeah let's go and he's like and
he's the first one to be like so the
plan's to go yeah let's go you guys want
some I'm involved
is going on
don't these trees
beesbury's Castle is called honey Holt
which is just adorable why did we kill
the sweetest the sweetest man with the
sweetest honey uh but yeah you gotta
watch out for those meisters
in it okay oh boy uh yeah watch out for
your Masters if you got a maester watch
out because they're they're working
against your best interest I think they
got their own little plan I don't know
what they're doing I don't know I I
don't trust them but I trust the silent
sisters I trust them more with medicine
than I trust this guy and they're just
embalming and liquefying people yeah um
okay uh there was a a Targaryen one of
Joe Harris's son that they sent to the
Citadel and he became an arch maester uh
and when the the question of who was
going to become out of the throne they
brought J Harris met with him for a
minute to be like you want to be the
king and he was like hell no absolutely
he was like have a great counsel I don't
know your damn mind yeah he like hated
people he just wanted to read his books
and I'm not trying to be that person
because I know how it works in royal
families
but it just seems like a good idea to
give it to the child that really wants
it because maybe they'll do something
with it versus they can't forcing the
kid that doesn't want to do anything
with it because then the person that
doesn't want to do it ruins everything
and destroys everything maybe like
wanting to be king means you shouldn't
be king well it's like at least you'll
do the job I'm not gonna do the job I'm
gonna go sleep around we know aegon's
gonna I'm gonna go you to go
speaking of aegon sleeping around eating
goats let's talk about uh aegon's check
off bastards here okay uh Eric and Eric
when they're checking out the child
Fight Club uh metal as hell uh Eric with
an E points out to Eric with an a like
hey uh aegon's been here and he's also
leaving his bastards here uh which again
if you have a hyper blonde kid where
that's you should assume that's a
Targaryen it's gonna show up soon
because they're gonna be like there's
like 12 blonde children here and they
feel like they all are related to like
someone in that castle so not only is
aegon having these bastards but he's
leaving them at the child Fight Club
which he still comes to and still hangs
out at it is maybe betting for or
against his own bastards I don't know I
think this is important I think they're
going to come back at some point these
bastards uh their teeth are going to be
sharper their claws are going to be very
sharp and they're going to attack their
father one day uh also if we learn
anything from Game of Thrones when you
have that many bastard children they're
going to be the question of who gets
thrown next comes up and then it's all
distressed and horrible and lots of
murder so it's like all those kids are
gonna come back eventually I don't know
when but they're gonna come up yeah and
it's gonna be a a day of ruining well
when Jay Harris had the great Council
some of the people who put in petitions
to be the air we're like we're from like
uh across the narrow City or from other
places and they're like I'm a Targaryen
bastard yeah because like targaryens
would go off and like have good times
all over the place good time boys coming
to Good Time boys time boys having a
good old time uh but yeah I think this
is going to be very important because
much later on I think these bastards do
play a big role so watch out for any
blonde-headed bastards walking around
and there's gonna be a lot of them
there's gonna be a lot of them there's
gonna be a lot of them and aegon's
probably gonna make some more in the
meantime uh I love finally in this
episode too like so Kristin Cole's like
we're looking for someone that clearly
has distinct features of one of us when
they go to the pillow house and they're
like have you seen the prince and
they're like he hasn't been here for a
while we're a little too milk toasts for
what the president these days also good
to see you again amen yeah boy how
you've grown she said hey baby he gives
a little yeah his grunts are are great
eamon's grunts are like great actor
great grunts great grunts uh Jessica is
this the end of the White Worm no way
right no I didn't see a body I didn't
see a body buzzing in there she's the
sneakiest person Messiah yeah you think
fire's going to put her out yeah do you
think she sees that coming yeah you
don't think she sees that coming she
sees everything yeah yeah I I think it's
maybe it's one it's sending a message
right 100. people who know know that the
White Worm lives there and anyone who
sees it is gonna be like I'm gonna stop
messing with the white worm I don't want
to go there anymore this was all very
this is a very Illuminating episode for
the White Worm I think even though we
have very little of it because we talked
about last week when we saw Talia go to
the white worms yeah we didn't know
under what pretenses she was going there
right did Auto send her there did did uh
was she working for massari or was she
working for Allison who was she working
for now we learned that like
I don't think Otto sent her Allison
definitely didn't send her and went and
very early in the episode when Talia
finds out the king is dead she goes to
that window and she lights those candles
in a very specific window I think is a
signal for the White Worm yeah she never
gets to leave the castle right yeah and
the white worm when she meets with Otto
she's like I know your King's dead or
not I was like what
he throws that money quick he goes like
get the bag
shut this lady up shut this lady up that
was so funny that scene was so funny
yeah so it's clear that like Otto has
used her and gotten information from her
but is not in control of this situation
she's not working for Otto she's working
for herself uh and I still think she
might be working with Damon a little bit
and I think these actions today would
even push her closer to Damon yeah
she's like I've helped you out High
towers and now you're screwing me over
and I think that's the best part is that
house won a flame Otto's gonna be like I
didn't do that you're right and then
Allison once like if he finds out that
it was Allison's message he's going to
be like what a stupid child we needed
like we needed that and you ruined it
and now they're gonna play for the other
side yeah like I don't care if we kill
every person in this castle that worked
with her she'll find another way in and
look at what you did yeah made us look
weak made us look so weak yeah that was
an interesting play uh it was
because I I agree Jessica it's like if
you're gonna kill her you gotta make
sure she's dead you can't just light her
house on fire yeah and honestly you can
kill her and then like hilarious people
they love fire and eventually it's like
Fire doesn't always get everything like
you know there's gonna be like stuff
that's missing there's Peppers there's
people
um and also yeah just double check to
make sure the bodies are there you
stupid also if you're working for Laris
you had your tongue cut out Now's the
Time to learn how to read and write okay
we need collateral now okay maybe week
one it was fun burning burning down
houses but like a few months in a few
years in switch it up you're like I'm
tired of burning these houses people
know we're doing it now yeah people know
it's us keep saying like I want to see
those toesies I'm like I don't want to
talk to this guy today I don't really
feel like
I like him stinky dip it in water and he
drinks the water
um he definitely drinks the foot water
she batheses
um either way I think it's also like not
to be Allison though I I agree with
everything she said about her dad and
being like I'm not gonna follow you
anymore but I'm like he has more years
of being scheming and sneaky and knowing
what is actually I play versus you so
setting that house on fire was a stupid
idea right a bad idea and he knows why
and way to make you guys look bad he's
he's gonna he's gonna he's gonna suss
that out and he's not yeah he's gonna be
so much I'm like now that aegon's in
place does he need Allison anymore
I mean I know that's his daughter but
the way he's used her up to this point
like this yeah she can't overplay her
hand now right it's so interesting and I
hate um I I mean yeah we've gone like
daddy issues or mommy issues and Game of
Thrones before but it's like how far is
he gonna go for his mom's love and is he
just gonna cut it off and be like well
now I have especially with odd if Elise
Otto is the hand which I assume he's
gonna do this is very much like Tywin
being in charge of Joffrey again right
yes it's like the king's drunk send him
to bed you know the king's tide is going
to bed I don't want to go to bed dad
Granddad go to bed uh and we already
know that like Otto doesn't
care for aegon yes or at the funeral
when he like found him drunk and he like
kicked him up yeah he he I think he
wants amen more than anything I hope you
died
uh Jessica before we get to our power
engines today I want to do a little flea
bottom fit check okay our boys our boys
put on their hoodies today and they went
down to flea bottom to find aegon uh the
thing I love mostly about Game of
Thrones you put a cape on with a hood
suddenly no one knows who knows who the
eye patch Prince is no one recognizes
you you put on a cape in a hood you can
do whatever you want in King's Landing
uh let's start first with the twins
let's check out the twins flea bottom
fit check a little boring you know they
got hoods uh they're not wearing it yeah
it's hard to tell here but they had
different embroidery that's how you
could kind of keep track of the twins
it's it's plain it's basic they were
told to take off their white cloaks they
followed the rules yeah but it's still
easy to spot because uh she noticed them
immediately yeah yeah she's like I'm
looking for you too and they're like we
don't want your ass woman yeah like shut
up she's like boy I got information I
got corn uh all right let's check out
eamon's fit flea bottom fit uh let's
check out eamon's fit check here let's
check this out oh oh yeah now this is
good it's still it looks a little
wealthy you know what I mean if you're
really trying to think which part of the
eye patch well the eye patch it's got
like it's a very nice thick very good
cloak yeah it's got that like gold
little chain there okay but it's pretty
good I mean if you you can't see the
hair which is important he's keeping his
hair locked away even though the lady
that runs this pillow house was like I
know the I remember you I don't remember
and he only made it out to sound like
he's only been there once and it was
when he was very very young so it's like
this woman immediately was like oh he
was there to get it wet get it wet yeah
he said we're gonna get it what he was
so uh like embarrassed about even having
to be like this is my [ __ ] brother my
brother forced me into this I went with
him he's an idiot he got it wet he got
it wet all right our next we bottom fit
check let's check out uh everyone's
favorite Psychopaths sir Kristen Cole
gotta hate him fresh off of killing an
old man heads down to flea bottom
Okay order it looks ridiculous he looks
like Jughead he looks so stupid he said
I'm gonna Hide My Curls no one will know
me I mean come on my guy get a hood
don't wear the little yeah he's a little
stupid I don't like this he's
progressively becoming egotistical you
know
[ __ ] and you look like one I hate
that he does look like a little F hand
he's like I don't need to hide I'm just
a Christian Cole I am now the nor the
new what is he what is she just announce
anoint anoint him well he's headed that
he's Lord Commander yeah Lord
commanderch now he's like he took this
job yeah yeah he gets to Crown the king
and all that stuff uh
yeah yeah I don't like his outfit it's
it's yeah it's stupid he clearly wants
to be noticed right I also love when he
was like he said something there that
like every Maiden deserves respect or
something like that uh right before they
go to the pillow house uh this is also
the guy who called Romero spoiled yeah
okay let's keep it in check I don't
remember what what you uh
I'm fit check is our boy
Otto came out
I like this no it looks good no he looks
like he came straight out of Lord of the
Rings no I I was saying you could put
him in the Mandalorian you know I mean
he could be walking around tattooing
dressing like literally is someone high
up he looks at look he's so stoic like
that he's not hiding from anyone I like
it I think I like it but I'm still like
this is a this is a man of money yeah
that's hanging out having a little money
hey man the minute money come down there
people recognize the prince they saw
Damon and raniera down there I love how
yeah the small folk are like okay uh I
just had sex with the King last night
they're like I don't know who you are
you have a hood on he literally comes
down here every night also God you guys
need to lock up your stuff better if
these kids keep getting out so easily uh
I don't think oh you're talking about
who's kids the aegon oh yeah I mean like
I know that because we know from Rainier
there's hidden in passages I think
they're aware of that he's sneaking out
Eric Eric with a knee points out uh that
aegon abuses his power because they can
order them around he's like go do that
and while he's doing that he like sneaks
out there's a lot of precedent of that
in in the book Fire and Blood previous
generations would take advantage of the
fact that because everyone all like
joharis and his wife uh Allison were
always like oh they're our kids won't
get up to too much stuff there's always
people around there's you know maids and
guards and Lords and Ladies and all this
stuff but they just order them away and
then they go mess around and do stuff
yeah keep your people in check uh okay
Jessica let's get to our power rankings
this week for House of the Dragon who's
up in power who gained the most power
this week on House of the Dragon aegon
aegon I mean it's Gotta Be aegon he
didn't even want it yeah he didn't want
it but he didn't want it as soon as he
got it he was like oh I like this he was
like they love me yeah they love me you
really love me I mean you could argue
that Allison and or Auto gain the most
power but like they're not in control of
they go aegon can literally be like
you're fired yeah I don't give a crap
about you yeah yeah let's go pillage
like he can do whatever he wants yeah uh
it and that's I I love Allison but like
that talk with them in the carriage I
was like what are you what do you mean
like what are you saying he does not
need to listen to you like you are
trying to persuade him so hard but you
slap the [ __ ] out of him like last
episode you and him you and viserys have
shown no love to him he does not need to
listen to you at all what are you trying
to redeem he doesn't think his dad ever
loved him he doesn't think his mom love
it he says do you love me she's like you
imbecile that's her response you don't
if you ask someone if they love you and
they say you imbecile they don't love
you they don't love you they don't love
you uh she's just so bad she's like if
we can just get through today yeah
everything's gonna be fine you can't
kill your sister you can't kill their
family you can't and he's like well do
you love me and she's like shut up you
idiot listen and I'm like great he's
gonna go kill everybody he's not gonna
listen to her at all yeah I think if
Otto shows him like any amount of Praise
he's gonna do whatever honestly anyone
he's gonna be jerking off through the
window again he's gonna be like the town
loves me I love it we're gonna make it
rain on this town
uh gross who who lost the most power
this week on House of the Dragon here's
my pitch yeah let me hear yours with
someone who wasn't even in the episode
it's rhaenyra I mean yeah
yeah appearance is everything and
thousands of small folk just saw a new
person Crown King and to them they're
like okay that's my king now I don't
have much say in this I just sell bricks
at The Brick Market I I I agree and I'm
also trying to argue why I think rainies
would and I'm only basing that off of
what everyone saw happen you think
Randy's lost a lot of power yeah because
uh you're gonna see her does her Town
her she's small but she's clearly not on
Allison's side so it's like okay well
she's with she's with the bad people and
then the small folks saw it too and
they're like okay they're with they're
bad people so it's like she doesn't
really have anything to stand on yeah
and then she just made herself look
really plus she just flew away and now
they can be like this that terrorists
beautiful day we gotta kill every Dragon
yeah exactly so that's why I'm like I
would argue that only because she dug
herself a hole where rhaenera didn't dig
anything yet she doesn't know she
doesn't have anything yet so that's why
I'm like next episode maybe I'll choose
right now at the beginning but right now
it's I think it's rainy's for me yeah
it's definitely really nice and it's
definitely Lord beesberry oh
that guy and they were like I need to
discuss with my house and he was like
you can't leave I was like how are you
gonna make these people you guys had a
whole Council you're gonna make these
one people make up their mind on the
spot I would like I get it you don't
want them to leave because then they'll
be telling the news right but it's like
you even had a council of five and then
you're gonna kill me if I leave to go
talk to my Council of five like [ __ ] be
for real be for real be for real well
that's the cost of doing business in
King's Landing uh and that's it I hate
this episode for this episode of big
question presents talking dragons
Jessica hate it the reason I hated it
pure emotion yeah out of emotion not out
of like writing not out of anything that
had any it's just me being like yeah I
it's it's Game of Thrones again just
getting so upset getting like
authentically mad yeah and being like
it's a show Jessica it's a show it's a
show based off a fictional book stop it
and I'm like every time Allison had told
someone like oh the king's changed my
life my wife screams didn't no he didn't
you weren't listening shut up shut up
I'm just I mean the kids are named yeah
exactly and we I know I know what you
were like well no one knows no one knows
no one knows but I'm like I'm still mad
that we have not not even a joke not
even like a mimic has been made of like
well there's two eggs and I don't know
how much Allison remembers of what was
even said at this point because like in
her mind she's filling in the place now
yeah and every time she tells the story
it's gonna get a little more like he's
set up and he said he did yeah I must
make my aegon kid he's the prince that
was promised and good writing for them
because I'm like genuinely that's human
that's how humans act that's how we act
it's like once we I mean you heard this
thing right but every time you have to
like say it to someone and you also have
to win them over in that fact you're
gonna start uh inch more and more
towards like he sat down got up pointed
to aegon and said it to him so it
changes over time and then through
history it's gonna probably warp itself
into something completely different but
I'm like that's kind of hard to come
across on TV to the audience that is
like
oh no that doesn't happen we all know
the truth but this was not in the book
this is all the stuff for the show uh
which is very fascinating so yes be sure
to join us here next week where we'll be
discussing the final episode of House of
the Dragon uh and then we'll do a
wrap-up show the week after that to
answer any lingering questions uh but
thank you unless the last episode pisses
me off unless you can't handle after the
last episode uh but thanks so much for
joining us today be sure to join us here
next week uh Eric's breakdown of the
episode will be up on the channel
tomorrow uh and don't forget to check
out our mini great merch options over at
New rockstarsmerch.com follow Jessica at
Lulu underscore Clemons follow me at
grin and Barrick and make sure you
subscribe to new rockstars wherever you
get your podcast or you watch it or
anything you do just subscribe subscribe
to our social channels as well thanks
for watching have a great rest of your
day and like we love to say around here
yes why didn't she say it
[Music]